bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7,8 week-end comme tous
les vendredis nous allons faire le point
des moments forts de l'actualité culture
loisirs et sports de la semaine pendant
26 minutes mais tout d'abord vous le
savez ce samedi 8 mars sera célébrée la
journée internationale de la femme c'est
l'occasion de mettre en avant la
condition féminine et dans le domaine de
l'aviation devenir pilote pour la gente
féminine a été autrefois un long combat
pour découvrir cette histoire une
exposition qui s'intitule femmes pilotes
des pionnières aux astronautes retrace
un siècle dans les airs à la salle
voltaire de fontenay fleuri à partir de
ce samedi 8 mars et pour en parler
michel c'est niet vous êtes chargé des
relations publiques de l'association
française des femmes pilotes bonjour à
vous et merci d'être là tout d'abord
première question pourquoi une telle
exposition sur les femmes pilotes et
bien parce qu'il ya une très belle
histoire que peu de gens connaissent et
donc on a décidé de faire des panneaux
qui retracent effectivement toute cette
saga
je le disais il ya ça fait un petit peu
plus d'un siècle que le tout premier
brevet de pilote a été accordé à une
femme que va-t-on y découvrir dans cette
exposition alors on va découvrir
différents thèmes c'est à dire qu'on a
les pionnières ce sont toutes les femmes
qui ont été brevetés avant 1914 après il
ya eu une interruption et on attaque
vers 1920 on aura donc les aventurières
qui l'avons commencé à faire des grands
voyages nous avons également un thème
sur les pilotes handicapés
sur les ips à ce sont les infirmières de
l'air nous avons les pilotes de ligne
les pilotes de chasse pilote d'essais
pilotes militaires et claudie haigneré
on la voit la célèbre exposition raconte
du coup le destin de toutes ces femmes
pilotes n'a rien à perdre le temps est
très à travers les âges quel rôle ont
elles joué dans l'évolution peut-être de
l'aviation aux cartes de la condition du
pilotage surtout que ça les a beaucoup
aidé pour sortir un peu du giron
familial
c'était une forme d'émancipation pouvoir
sortir et donc beaucoup de femmes se
sont accrochés à ça pour pouvoir
justement
s'émanciper des traditions féminine
c'était difficile pour une femme jusqu'à
une certaine période à peu près les
années 70 je crois pour être accepté
dans les airs et dans l'est dans les
écoles il est très clair que les femmes
n'étaient pas pilote de ligne
la première qui a été acceptée c'est en
67 sur air inter ensuite la première à
air france et 1974 et très longtemps au
final a très longtemps et l'école
d'aviation civile enac n'a été ouverte
aux femmes qu'en 1974 comment peut-on
expliquer justement ce retard c'était
quoi c'était un manque de reconnaissance
de l'excellence deux baies pilotes
femmes ou bacille on estimait que les
femmes n'avaient pas piloté je sais moi
je pense que c'est un peu ça et c'était
fermé et les hommes ont fait ce qu'il
fallait pour que ça t'ouvre pas trop
vite je crois et la plupart de ces
femmes pilotes dont vous avez parlé elle
avait tout un parcours spécifique pour
venir l'aviation alors certaines sont
partis deux pilotes d'aero club il ya
souvent des gens qui démarre dans les
aéroclubs et puis qui trouve la vocation
est pour beaucoup oui daniel des curés
je tendrais son nom en 74 première à air
france eh bien elle est sortie par le
vol à voile le vol moteur les aéro club
jacqueline du but je crois qu'elle a
fait un peu pareil aussi également
souvent ses airs club qu'on voit entre
autres dans notre région forme des
futurs pilotes de ligne des futurs
pilotes de chasse la vocation bien
souvent de là mais on le rappelle les
aînés sont un territoire quand même oui
d'aviation puisqu'il ya plusieurs
aérodrome à saint cyr à toussus-le-noble
notamment et c'est vrai que il ya
beaucoup de femmes pilotes qui sont
passés par les idées au 20ème siècle et
on avait même beaucoup plus l'aérodrome
puisque certains ont été fermés
d'ailleurs et personnellement je crois
que vous aussi vous avez été pilote mais
en faisant aussi de la compétition alors
racontez nous un petit peu votre
histoire par rapport au pilotage alors
moi j'ai été formé disons que je suis né
dans une famille héros nautique et donc
dès ma naissance j'ai été sur les
aérodromes et bien entendu j'ai accroché
sur le sujet et j'ai commencé à piloter
à la première fois sol j'avais 15 ans
j'ai passé le brevet à 17 ans comme on
ne peut pas le passé avant et après j'ai
très vite enchaîné sur de la compétition
du rallye aérien de la course de vitesse
tout ce qui était précision puis la
voltige la voltige imagine que ça a été
le moment de votre carrière de pilote le
plus apprécié est peut-être alors à
cécile top et vous vouliez sur quel type
d'appareil alors moi j'ai fait les
championnats de france de voltige
aérienne en 66 à fayence sur ce qu'on
appelle un avion ce temps c'est à dire
un avion biplan avec la tête à l'air
donc on est pendus dans des bretelles m
je me dire s'il ya deux diaby et des
sécurités
et je le disais en introduction vous
faites partie de l'association française
des femmes pilotes du oui elle a été
créée en 1971 pour la petite histoire
quel rôle at-elle joué cette association
eba entre août c'est elle qui a réussi à
faire ouvrir les portes de l'école
nationale d'aviation civile en 1974 ces
quelques femmes qui se sont réunis en
disant il faut qu'on fasse bouger les
choses et donc depuis maintenant je
dirais que pratiquement toutes les
portes sont ouvertes que ce soit chez
les militaires pilote de chasse chez les
militaires pilote de transport toutes
les portes sont ouvertes mais
aujourd'hui on existe toujours parce que
on fait de la promotion parce qu'il n'ya
pas assez de femmes
je dirais que dans l'ensemble il ya à
peu près 7% de femmes ce qui est quand
même pas beaucoup le fossé est encore et
encore tous grands voilà donc voilà on
fait on fait de l'histoire et puis on
essaie de développer envie aux jeunes
d'aller sur ces métiers c'est dû à quoi
ce manque de femmes au volant d avion c
un manque de passion ou c'est parce que
justement les jeunes femmes croient que
c'est trop fermé c'est peut-être
peut-être au masculin voilà c'est un peu
ça et je pense que notre rôle justement
c'est de faire passer un autre message
alors j'ai feuilleté un petit peu le
livre que vous avez écrit un des livres
que vous avez écrit notamment sur ces
femmes pilotes pionnière jusqu'au dont
le titre était pionnière aux astronautes
et il ya une pilote qui a retenu mon
attention elle s'appelle hélène boucher
elle était pilote au début du xxème
siècle dans les années 30
particulièrement mais elle a une
malheureuse histoire avec un aérodrome
et l'aérodrome de guyancourt et
racontez-nous samedi à d'abord une belle
histoire d'une belle histoire il ya une
belle histoire sa carrière est très très
courte c'est à peu près trois ans 3 ans
et demi elle est passée par tous les
stades bon l'apprentissage bien entendu
elle a touché à des grands voyages
puisqu'elle avait tenté un pari saigon
elle a touché à la voltige et elle a
touché un record de vitesse et donc en
1934 elle a battu les records du monde
de vitesse sur
c'était pas lui en course était sur
istres et les avions étaient basés
guyancourt puisque ce sont les avions
caudron et donc qu'elle a battu les
records à 445 km heure avec un avion à
hélice pas un avion à réaction déjà ça
allait très vite c'était des beaux
avions des avions très très fuselées ce
très très beaux habits et donc son
histoire malheureusement s'est terminé
alors tu es de l'union jeu direct voilà
est là elle a fait tout tout tout en
trois ans est là elle a touché à tout et
puis elle a voulu s'entraîner un jour eu
ces mauvais temps pendant le salon de
l'aéronautique qui était à paris et avec
le mauvais temps elle manquait aussi un
petit peu d'entraînement parce que là
est fait de la compétition puis elle
s'était un peu arrêté et donc elle a été
prise dans le mauvais temps
malheureusement est là
loupé un atterrissage et que fait-on
quand on est plus pilotes j'imagine que
vous pilotez peut-être un peu moins
aujourd'hui c'est difficile cette
attirance des airs qui doit être encore
là non à bâle - la passion ali est
toujours la passion elle y est toujours
mais bon j'ai pu de visite médicale j'ai
un passé lourd donc ma foi je reste dans
le milieu parce que c'est un milieu
passionnant et donc je me suis mis à
faire de l'histoire de l'écriture de
l'histoire et puis comme ça je m'occupe
un peu des expositions je reçois des
jeunes des classes où les motive à ce
genre de métier très bien merci beaucoup
michel sénia d'être passés sur le 7-8
week-end et si vous voulez donc
découvrir plein de profil atypique de
pilotes de femmes pilotes rendez vous
donc pour l'exposition femmes pilotes
des pionnières aux astronautes qui
débute ce 8 mars jusqu'au 17 mars salle
voltaire à fontenay le fleury merci
beaucoup à vous ici on reste dans la
journée internationale de la femme
jusqu'au 2 mars cette fois ci du côté de
magny les hameaux les femmes sont
célébrées à travers différentes
manifestations aux couleurs cette année
de l'amérique du sud tour d'horizon
complet avec aurélien de bissy
à magny les hameaux ce n'est pas une
journée mais une semaine durant laquelle
la femme les femmes du monde sont
célébrées à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes le
samedi 8 mars la ville et les
associations partenaires organisent une
semaine d'animations cette année sur la
thématique de l'amérique du sud au
programme par exemple visite à
l'estaminet de deux expositions
consacrées aux femmes d'amérique latine
atelier cuisine ou tacos et autres
aiment pas nada se réveille les papilles
ou encore cours de gym en rythme sur des
musiques en ou caliente
au travers de ces invitations au voyage
l'objectif est de créer des moments de
partage et d échange pour les femmes on
ne fait pas désaltéré pour faire des
ateliers faut que ça a un sens et le
sens et le lien entre elles avec les
autres
passent rarement autres femmes
d'ailleurs de ce que la semaine de la
femme ça concerne pas que les femmes
on est invités etc et c'est vrai que ça
ça permet vraiment de elles font
connaissance de plus en plus entre elles
elles
échangeront au niveau de leurs enfants
par rapport à leurs enfants par rapport
à l'éducation c'est le sens et ça c'est
le lien social qu'elle tisse entre elles
voilà et avec le quartier avec la vie et
puis c'est aussi une façon de comment
dire de faire comprendre aux femmes de
se comprendre nous mêmes aussi
de quoi on est capable en fait ce que
l'on veut c'est faire des tas de choses
on peut faire des tas de choses on le
sait tout le monde ne le sait pas mais
bon voilà c'est prendre confiance en
nous le plus en plus je crois qu'on y
est on y arrivera coup comme ça
gagner en confiance en soi se sentir à
l'aise avec son corps et oser être belle
ce sont là les maîtres mots donnés au
cours de l'atelier de conseil en image
dispensés également cette semaine s'est
donné des astuces et des conseils
faciles à réaliser au quotidien
et pour tout public voilà jeunes moins
jeunes parce qu'en fait le loup qui
concerne tout le monde j'aime beaucoup
cette ce lien qui se tisse avec les
dames ce côté aussi où on laisse tous
les soucis on parle un peu chiffon parle
beauté le consomme amant jeunes à la
recherche d'emploi c'est ce côté entre
femmes super hein
mon image et se laisse un peu s confie
on rigole
l'atelier aux allures de réunion entre
amis apportent les clés pour apprendre
notamment à se maquiller associer les
couleurs qui met en valeur et s'habiller
en fonction de sa morphologie parce que
c'est mon regard devient par rapport à
tout à l'oeuvre devait trouver
différents les yeux ça peut aider voilà
reprendre confiance en soi
ensuite un divorce une issue recherche
d'emploi enfin des diverses choses dans
ce sens on se sent soutenu aidé s'est
fait dans la joie et dans la bonne
humeur et avec beaucoup de dents
d'empathie
la journée du samedi 8 mars annonce elle
aussi sous le signe de la convivialité
de 10 heures à 16 heures place au
plaisir sportif entre autres cours
d'aéroboxe zumba rallye pédestre et dès
20h30 la soirée se clôture par le
concert salsa le yemaya la banda 12
musicienne venus des quatre coins du
monde
la ferme de la ferme pédagogique pardon
de la base de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines vous fait découvrir chaque
dimanche le parcours du lait de la
traite à sa transformation en fromage
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images
comment manipuler les trayons de chèvre
la ferme pédagogique de la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
propose tous les dimanches matin un
atelier d'initiation destiné aux enfants
toutes les étapes de transformation du
lait en fromage sont au programme à
commencer par la traite des chèvres le
but c'est vraiment d'apprendre en
s'amusant et posant des petites
questions par exemple pour le lait de
savoir qu'une chèvre elle a besoin
d'avoir un bébé pour pour faire du lait
on demande à quoi ça sert le lait pour
enfin pour nourrir qui pour nourrir le
bébé et il trouve intuitivement les
enfants apprennent ensuite les rudiments
de la fabrication du fromage le lait
filtré afin d'enlever toutes les
impuretés quelques gouttes de présure
d'origine animale sont rajoutés pour
coagulé le lait et après une journée
d'attenté il faut des goûters le lait
caillé dans des faisselles le fromage
doit ensuite être salée est placé sur
une grille muni d'un store d'égouttage
il ne manque plus que l'affinage et le
séchage j'ai trouvé ça très intéressant
et on s'est bien amusé yang rigole et je
m'étais jamais entaché achats et
maintenant m
j'aime bien savoir mais pas question de
dégustation à l'issue de l'atelier pour
des normes d'hygiène le fromage doit
reposer avant d'être goûter
en sport sept semaines le golfe de
feucherolles accueillez la première
étape de la football cup 2014 l'occasion
de découvrir ce sport a priori fait pour
les anciens footballeurs et surtout une
discipline en quête de reconnaissance
jonathan willeman pour les images
il ne porte plus le même maillot et
pourtant ils continuent de frapper dans
le même ballon mais sur un parcours de
golf avec des chaussettes hautes un
gilet et un béret vous êtes au football
les règles sont celles du golfe sauf
qu'ici pas de clubs seulement des pieds
pour faire entrer le ballon dans un trou
de 55 cm de diamètre en un minimum de
coups pas si facile même quand on a
marqué près de 100 buts dans sa carrière
de footballeur ça paraît simple sa part
été simple vue on a l'impression que que
c'est très simple mais finalement les
distances sont relativement faussé par
encore vous avez un terrain de foot où
c'est beaucoup plus rapprochés la cia
n'a distancé dur à jauger et après
moyens forcément le terrain facile
photo ap on a toujours peur de se
blesser mais c'est très sympa né aux
pays-bas en 2009 la discipline compte
désormais seize fédérations dans le
monde l'argentine a d'ailleurs remporté
la première coupe du monde en 2012 et la
prochaine pourrait bien être organisé en
france mais pour cela les foudres
golfeurs doivent d'abord être acceptée
sur les greens fin 2014 on espère avoir
deux mille cinq cents licenciés et à
horizon de trois ans et d'avoir entre
cinq et dix mille licenciés qu'ils
puissent va commencer à pratiquer on
sait que pour ça de toute façon ça passe
par le fait que les que certains golfs
nous accepte pour une pratique régulière
parce que vont venir jouer comme ça il
faut tendance est marrant c'est ludique
mais c'est vrai que je pense que naquit
peuvent s'y prendre se prendre au jeu et
commence à avoir envie de jouer
régulièrement comme au golf ou comme au
foot 3 golfe viennent de signer un
partenariat avec l'association française
de football pour accueillir ce nouveau
sport les pays-bas venus en masse à
feucherolles ont marqué leur territoire
en remportant l'épreuve par équipes de
cette première étape de la foudre gold
cup 2014
il s'apprête à traverser le pacifique à
la rame en juin prochain clément et
christophe prendront le départ de la
great pacific raïs pour peut-être
établir un record du monde nous les
avons rencontrés il ya quelques jours
dans leur village demi ils m'ont tout
près d'houdan avec jonathan widemann et
patrick jacques de dixmude
pourquoi une traversée à la rame comme
vous le disiez clément vous n'êtes pas
tous les deux des marins furent sans nom
allez on est on est pas des marins
pur-sang
maintenant au contact des marins on a
compris que c'était possible ce qui est
sûr c'est que la traversée à la rame
c'est quelque chose qui reste unique
dans le monde aujourd'hui il ya 650
personnes qui ont traversé un mot sur la
rame et l'océan pacifique donc nous
c'est la course qu'on va faire c'est san
francisco hawaï pour l'instant du moins
de 40 personnes qui l'ont fait
évidemment ce qui nous arrive et c'est
un côté unique exploit vous partez de 2
0 pour ainsi dire il va falloir
apprendre un peu tous là naviguer rats
mais aussi l'aspect physique parce que
j'imagine que la condition physique doit
être parfaite pour partir dans ce genre
d'expédition dans la vallée c'est sûr
que c'est un projet qui est extrêmement
complet que ce soit pour une préparation
en terme de budget pour trouver les
sponsors que ce soit en préparation
physique c'est très difficile de pouvoir
utiliser un bateau comme ça m'étonnerait
qu'on habite en région parisienne ce que
le bateau se trouve en région parisienne
c'est compliqué d'aller en mer
régulièrement donc on s'entraîne tout
simplement sur des rameurs classique
deux chambres et ensuite c'est beaucoup
de courses à pied l'idée c'est en fait
d'être en très bonne forme et grâce à
notre préparation qui est assez
spécifique on peut on va essayer
d'augmenter nos performances pendant les
quatre derniers mois qu'ils nous restent
avant le départ de la course c'est
justement des techniques qui sont assez
faciles à apprendre parce que comme vous
le disiez peu de personnes ont tenté ce
genre de traverser c'est que l'exploit
est quand même d'une certaine hauteur
non alors c'est compliqué d'atteindre le
bon niveau physique c'est un effort qui
comme un effort de marathonien sauf
qu'on le répète tous les jours c'est 10
heures de rame par personne par jour
donc ça fait une grosse part du gâteau
qui va falloir manger tous les jours
avoir fait pour ça pendant environ une
cinquantaine de jours minimum
cinquantaine de jours et au niveau des
techniques de la mer en fait c'est
justement ce week end en europe d'un
week-end de formation à la science dire
haute mer donc une formation fait avec
des marins qui font la route du rhum la
solitaire du figaro un des dégâts qui
ont une expérience de malade et c'est
pas des techniques qui sont forcément
très compliqué par contre il faut
l'avoir fait une fois pour pas paniquer
au moment où on est à la baille et où il
faut sortir les fusées de détresse si on
lance la fusée de détresse dans le
mauvais sens on se la prend dans le
ventre et puis finalement
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça pas
été d'une grande aide et gérard
d'aboville je crois que vous l'avez
rencontrée c'est un bon le rappelle
c'est le premier homme à avoir traversé
à la rame un océan dans les années 80 en
1980 cette rencontre elle a été décisive
dans votre projet alors tout à fait même
même bien avant la rencontre en fait
gérard d'aboville a été décisif est une
grande source d'inspiration pour nous
parce que c'est le pionnier le pionner
de la ram océanique et tous et plus ces
bouquins tout ce qu'il a écrit
mais écrit notamment deux sur ces
traversée à la rame a vraiment ça nous
inspire et ça nous donne envie de ça
nous a vraiment donné envie de nous
lancer dans cette aventure vous le
disiez tout à l'heure clément il ya une
dimension historique parce que ce bateau
où nous sommes il a déjà parcouru un
petit peu quelques océans mais il ya
aussi la dimension historique parce que
si vous réussissez l'exploit de faire
cette traversée vous serez le l'équipage
le plus jeune qui aura réussi cette
traversée ça vous trotte beaucoup dans
la tête ça est évidemment
qui va se passer c'est que
quoi qu'il se passe quoi qu'il arrive le
jour opposera le piège on sera les plus
jeunes à l'avoir fait et c'est ce dont
on parlait au début il ya quelque chose
d'unique à faire une traversée à la rame
ça ajoute encore quelque chose de plus
nous pouvoir se dire que pour les autres
c'est pas tous des deux blocs mais en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que si on
arrive à faire ça ce sera ce sera ce
sera encore pour nous
deux journées deux victoires pour les
templiers d'elancourt en championnat de
france élite de foot us les joueurs
d'emmanuel charest se sont imposés ce
week-end face aux molosses d'asnières et
il confirme là évidemment leurs
ambitions de titre image de patrick
jacques de dixmude
en 2014 les templiers ferme d'abord la
porte de leur en-but ensuite sur leur
série au fonds cible il fait confiance
aux jeunes shenton nouveau quarterback
américain montre tout son talent en
réalisant une impressionnante course
face à la défense adverse
deux actions plus tard il trouve son
receveur anthony couvin qui prochaine
son défenseur avant de filer au coach
donne pour une réception de plus de 45
yards 7 0 ça c'est vraiment très bien
passé bon il faut dire qu'on a donc on a
cinq six receveurs qui sont très très
bons 3 400 mg r du shopping france donc
on facilite un peu l'arrivée du
quaterback lui il est bon il fait ce
qu'il faut on avait les receveurs en
face voilà ça c'est la collection c'est
vite passé il est de taille mais
maintenant il ya un mois et demi ils ont
tout va bien au début du second quart
temps les templiers mène rapidement 14 0
mais leurs affaires se compliquent
brutalement après l'expulsion d'anthony
couvin pour un coup de casque sur
alexandre marvel mais les molosses ne
concrétisent pas leurs possessions 14 0
à la mi temps
au retour des vestiaires jeunes shelton
impeccable jusque-là va remettre les
molosses dans le match par une perte de
balle à quelques mètres de l'en but
adverse
un turn-over qui offrent leur deuxième
match dans nos visiteurs 14 sept les
molosses ne parviendront pas à revenir
et béraud leurs espoirs douchés par un
dernier touchdown de christophe morin et
surtout cette interception de thibaut
pourchon score final 21 sept avec cette
deuxième victoire en autant de journées
les templiers s'annonce clairement comme
l'une des équipes à battre de ce début
de saison
allez pour terminer cette édition
évidemment place à votre agenda du
week-end de rendez vous à ne pas rater
ces deux prochains jours on en parlait
évidemment pour en début d'émission
l'exposition femmes pilent des
pionnières aux astronautes à la salle
voltaire de fontenay le fleury vous
pourrez découvrir ces femmes pilotes
jusqu'au 17 mars et on sport
championnats de france de cross-country
ce dimanche 9 mars au au parc maurice le
luc de saint cyr l'école
départ à 10 heures c'est la fin de cette
édition merci et encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end sur tv fille